At Central Elementary in Union, Missouri, the best teachers may just be two students.
First graders Vincent Butterfield and Zac Gossage are very good friends.
Last June, after feeling ill and tired for weeks,...
...Zac was diagnosed with acute lymphoblastic leukemia.
Still, while everybody around him took it hard, Zac took it in stride.
As for Vincent, he started asking questions and learning about cancer.
Vincent also found out that Zac might lose his hair because of the chemotherapy treatments.
One day, he showed up to Mrs. Koester's first grade class wearing a stocking cap.
"I have a surprise for Zac."
And I said, "Well, you do."
And he pulls off his stocking cap and here I see that he shaved his head.
"I cut it off."
"You cut off your hair?"
"Yeah."
"How come?"
"To make Zac feel like he's not the only one without any hair."
And Vincent, well he may be young, but he's teaching us the oldest lessons.
What is friendship?
"A beautiful thing."
Indeed it is.